lina estaba viendo un partido de fútbol
americano el equipo que apoyaba avanzó 6
yardas en una jugada perdió 8 yardas en
la siguiente jugada perdió otras dos
yardas en la siguiente jugada línea
quiere saber cuál fue el cambio neto de
su equipo en la posición del campo
después de estas tres jugadas cuando las
siguientes ecuaciones coincide con la
situación descrita arriba así que
pensemos en esto el equipo que apoyaba
ganó primero seis yardas son seis yardas
positivas luego perdió ocho serían seis
menos ocho y luego perdió otras dos y
seis menos ocho menos dos esto es seis
menos ocho pero luego más dos esto no es
correcto esto es seis más menos ocho lo
que equivale a seis menos ocho más menos
dos
esto sería equivalente a 6 menos 8 - 2
otra manera de pensar en eso ganó 6
yardas luego perdió 8 yardas y luego
perdió otras dos yardas definitivamente
él gire está
continuamos eduardo y francisco están
buceando eduardo está a 35 metros por
debajo de la superficie del agua y
francisco está 8 metros directamente
arriba de la siguiente ecuación describe
esta situación veamos
eduardo está a 35 metros por debajo de
la superficie del agua mientras estemos
por debajo de la superficie o mientras
estemos a una mayor distancia por debajo
del agua será un número más negativo
imagino que es lo que estamos haciendo
aquí en la superficie del agua estarás a
0 metros y nos dicen que francisco está
8 metros arriba de él así que si sabemos
que la profundidad de eduardo es de 35
metros y francisco está 8 metros por
arriba de él así que estamos sumando 8
para saber la profundidad de francisco
que
de menos 27 metros observa que esto es 8
metros arriba de la profundidad de
eduardo menos 27 es la profundidad de
francisco el estado 27 metros por debajo
de la superficie del agua
ahora selecciono todas las que apliquen
francisco esta 27 metros por debajo de
la superficie del agua
si eso es de lo que acabamos de hablar
menos 27 significa 27 metros por debajo
del agua y 27 positivo significa que
estas 27 metros por arriba del agua eso
es lo que nos dicen la posición de
francisco relativa a la superficie del
agua es de menos 27 metros
creo que esa es una manera razonable de
decirlo es un poco más confuso pero si
él está 27 metros por debajo de la
superficie del agua es lo que acabamos
de decir aquí por lo que creo esta
también es correcta hagamos uno más el
sótano de fabián está inundado el piso
del sótano está 3.4 metros por debajo de
la planta baja eso tiene sentido que el
sótano esté a 3.4 metros por debajo de
la planta baja el agua alcanza una
altura de 1.2 metros la siguiente
ecuación describe la situación - 3.4 eso
es la posición del piso del sótano 3.4
metros por debajo de la planta baja así
que la planta baja será 0 3.4 metros por
debajo de la planta baja eso es
es punto 4 pero el agua está a 1.2
metros la superficie del agua está a 1.2
metros por arriba del piso del sótano
este menos 2.2 es que tan alta está la
superficie del agua así que qué es lo
que nos dice menos 2.2 la superficie del
agua está 2.2 metros por debajo de la
planta baja
eso es correcto el agua está 1.2 metros
por encima del piso del sótano lo cual
son menos 2.2 metros y todo esto es
relativo a la planta baja si la planta
baja es 0 la superficie del agua es
menos 2.2 lo que significa que la
superficie del agua está 2.2 metros por
debajo eso es lo que nos dice el signo
negativo por debajo de la planta baja
el agua tiene 2.2 metros de profundidad
eso no es correcto nos dicen que la
altura del agua es de 1.2 metros o tiene
1.2 metros de profundidad esa no es
correcta y no voy a elegir la opción de
ninguna de las anteriores porque
definitivamente encontramos una
respuesta